la vida emerge de los escombros
esta es una de las decenas de personas
que se teme hayan quedado atrapadas bajo
un edificio de apartamentos bombardeado
por las fuerzas rusas los cohetes rusos
alcanzaron este complejo residencial de
5 plantas en una pequeña ciudad de la
región de donges en el este de ucrania
dos edificios de gran altura fueron
destruidos decenas de personas están
bajo los escombros
desde el comienzo de la invasión los
agentes de la ley ucranianos están
haciendo todo lo necesario para
registrar los crímenes de los ocupantes
y recoger pruebas muchos países nos
están ayudando con spanair
mientras las operaciones de rescate
continúan los sobrevivientes hicieron un
balance de lo que quedaba de sus hogares
algunos pudieron recuperar los pocos
objetos personales que quedaron intactos
tras el ataque algunos lograron escapar
mi hijo fue a ver dónde estaba el ataque
con misiles cuando atacaron por segunda
vez él y su padre quedaron inconscientes
agarró a su padre por los hombros y lo
arrastró entre los escombros lo arrastró
hasta la moto el ataque en donges que se
produce cuando moscú vuelva a centrar
sus esfuerzos en controlar la totalidad
de la región del donbass tras haber
tomado la vecina región de lugansk los
ataques del ejército de vladimir putin
contra la población civil continúan
mientras que occidente trata de
detenerlo con sanciones y en un pulso de
poder al margen del cual moscú detuvo
suministro de gas a alemania y a italia
a través del norte swing 1 en lo que
aseguró es un mantenimiento pero que
despierta temores de que el corte sea
definitivo